sweet is because i think a lot of actors
when they get roles like this they have
to say oh yeah no it's a thrill
but for you this is genuine because you
post these incredibly sweet pictures uh
this is you as a young boy
i mean you are playing with yourself
so that is so sweet and then this one
this is amazing you were i think back in
your house and you found this
so that was genuinely yours that was my
first ever spider-man costume yeah which
my lovely mum who's here tonight kept
for me and now were you one of those
kids you like wore it to funerals and
weddings
i was i slept in that thing that thing
still stinks today there's no washers
that can make that thing wearable
all right uh
am i right in thinking that the
spiderman outfit is as we knew it is
gone now no well yes yes it is basically
spoiler
essentially in this film i have a new
suit which tony stark gave me it's an
upgrade and uh it's too
fantastical to exist in real life so i
essentially there it is that's the first
time i've seen it wow it looks great
are you glad you came tonight i love you
so much oh it's nice
is that metal i don't know graham okay
so essentially i have to wear
essentially pajamas i wear these pajamas
with balls on them that light up and
it's super cool it's not and
you know i'm on set with the avengers
who are wearing costumes that you know
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars
made by the best seamstresses you can
imagine
and i'm there in a suit made by marks
and spencers you know it's just it's
martian spencer's is in english
of the highest quality
frameset all right absolute autograph
collection hello
this i find unbelievable that jason when
you were filming with jennifer you did
not spot her jewelry in this scene you
didn't know who here knows what that is
oliver's uh is it a [__] green
no i've actually been like oh honestly
yeah is it really that's what that is
coke
no one here knew that right so
no one here knew that did anyone know
that no no no that's a good answer
did anyone smell it during the day yes
they did that well then everybody else
kept saying that's a really nice
necklace that's gorgeous and sedakis of
course walks right up to me and he goes
is that a [__] ring
and i said really well you've just given
me some insight into your sweet personal
life yeah
all i knew what it was too
so embarrassed right now
oh poor ali yeah i know why'd you do
this to me
i guess no one told you life is going to
be this way
[Applause]
we've been here since five o'clock
rehearsal
has just been you guys have been
rehearsed
that's adorable that was really good do
that again
so i guess no one told you life is going
to be this way
so actually so here's the game now i'm
not going to say it again but if anyone
else wants to feed it into conversation
don't let me down
you did really good so far
don't spoil it what is the line again oh
uh no one ever told you life's gonna be
i look like look at me i'm trying to
remember it
i told you so my life was gonna be this
way
you guys are
it good become annoying
you could do this all night
i'm gonna wear damn judy dench out on
that
one
does matthew know that he plays a
special part in your life
uh no probably not please i play a
special part in your life yeah
can't wait to hear this well i mean
i
my wife and i sleep with you almost
every night yes
and every night there's an app called
calm
and i have insomnia and
he has the most beautiful voice and i
turn it on
and i just hear where hello everybody
it's me matthew mcconaughey i'm going to
tell you a bedtime story and i just do
this oh
i honestly got truth about it is my wife
who's from argentina she always goes
like you have the man talking again
the man is talking in the bed again
it's great though i love this it cost me
80 bucks
well it was well worth it out have you
been no we've got a little bit because i
just thought it was you really but you
are actually putting people to bed this
is this is matthew mcconaughey on the
app
tonight
i hope to send you off to peaceful
dreams with that very thing in mind
let your eyes close and your breath fall
soft and slow
as we begin our story
which just might rekindle
that sense of wonder
wake up
february the 14th valentine's day olivia
coleman what will you be doing on
valentine's day oh
uh
is this about the thing yes
i'll be watching a film
your film comes out on february the 14th
oh my god it's like pulling teeth
wait wait because i thought you meant
because the premieres before that so i
went actually watching on that day i
thought you meant what would i be doing
and i was thinking i don't know
a bit of whimsy in just
i'll be sitting with millions of others
in a cinema watching my new film cuban
fury so sorry i see what you did now
yeah yeah
thank you no this is a cuban fury a new
british comedy is yourself a nick frost
and yeah i'm not on the pitch
oh no that isn't you but it could be you
with the leg in the air yeah
now i could safely say ladies and
gentlemen without fear of contradiction
it is the best british-based salsa
rom-com i have ever seen
i think that can go in the poster yeah
for sure no it's a really funny sweet
though it's a lovely film now who are
you
um i can't actually remember the name of
my character but
it was a while ago
the last episode she was promoting a
film she didn't know who she was playing
in the film
it was finished it was in the cinema it
was a long time after we'd filmed
[Music]
contractually no offense but we're sort
of asked to come and all right
wow
she doesn't mean that i don't know
she doesn't want to be here
but i do wonder why they asked me to do
it
i don't help do i
i i'm thinking she's never been in one
of my phones
she's good
i like her thank you i like you
[Music]
you